my talk of the table was a movie
franchise that we all grew up with 25
years ago the killer ghostface he
terrified audiences in the original
scream movie and it was amazing now a
brand new installment of the popular
series is hitting theaters starring some
of the original cast including actor
david arquette now we should mention
it's distributed by paramount of viacom
cbs company now in this spine-tilling
sequel copycat killer is targeting a new
group of teens and arquette is reprising
his role as dewey riley in this clip
from the movie he gives teens advice on
how they can find and stop the new
killer check it out
there's certain rules to surviving a
stab movie
believe me i know
rule number one
never trust the love interest
they seem sweet caring supportive then
welcome to act three where they're
trying to rip your head off rule number
two the killer's motive is always
connected to something in the past
rule number three and this is the most
important rule the first victim always
has a friend group that the killer is a
part of look for the killer there if you
can find out why they're doing this you
can figure out who's next
david arquette joins us now so good and
he did his thing well done in this one
now the original scream uh came out over
uh we're talking about 25 years ago the
last one over 10 years ago and we know
that wes craven he produced and directed
the ones before what was it like
reprising that role and also how did
they convince you to come back for this
well i love playing the role of dewey
and we had to take in consideration
since wes wasn't going to be there and
be the first one he didn't direct
but matt and tyler the directors were
really fans of wes's and were inspired
by him so that set us at ease it was
really great working with nev and
courtney again
and we have an incredible new cast of
tremendous actors
hey david speaking i'm not supposed to
be there your character dewey riley was
supposed to die according to some
accounts in the very first screen but
there were alternate shots with you on
the stretcher with a thumbs up so i
guess they decided to make you live did
they still do it that way uh were you
shooting this with alternate scenes so
even the actors did not know how the
plot would twist and turn
they always are secretive about the
scripts and stuff but wes was really
gracious and he said well david i'm
going to put you in the gurney we'll see
if you make it or not so that was really
cool
you know david this i have to confess to
you this was the first screen movie i've
ever seen i only watched it because you
were coming on and i wanted to have some
sense of you and what this movie was
about because i don't like to be scared
so it goes from me not liking to be
scared to kill him kill him kill her
down 9-1-1 so i know it was crazy and
you watch it alone i don't recommend
that for anybody but are you the type of
person you like these scary movies
you must i do i love
yeah i love scary movies and i love the
environment of having everyone in an
audience screaming and
just i watch half of it like this too
yes yes i did do that you know what was
good about this movie is that the things
that you when you thought something was
going to happen like something as simple
as opening or closing a refrigerator
door or
opening and shutting a closet where you
thought something was going to happen
and then later it didn't happen isn't
that part of the fun to sort of trick
the audience and there are some plot
twists that we won't reveal along the
way
it actually is a really good story line
even for someone who had never seen a
scream movie
yeah there's a lot of really fun like
games that matt and tyler the directors
are playing with the audience there's a
lot as a tribute to wes there's a lot of
really sweet elements in the film but
it's still super scary and super gory
yes i really
think the fans are gonna love it
i do too david in october you know i
spoke with uh the directors matt and
tyler about the science of fear so i
have to ask and gail kind of alluded to
it you said that you love scary movies
you love the gore but what is your
favorite scary movie um they asked that
in the movie oh man
i always liked the shining because jack
nicholson's performance was so great in
that but there's so many great movies
coming out get out was incredible
hereditary's incredible midsomar like
there's just wild films coming out
you also have another side david in
addition to scary you like being a clown
you bought the rights to bozo he's in
clown school and you're in clown school
that just did not
is that you is that david
that's one of the older
okay
what is what is your appeal to cleveland
wgn
yeah what's your appeal with i love club
i was surprised to hear that i felt
i fell in love with clowns when i was a
kid in chicago watching bozo and he was
just
just i don't know it's joy and laughter
and i really want to bring that back to
the world i'm working with an
organization called healthy humor that
uh do medical clowning in in 15
hospitals throughout the country so i'm
going to study with them in february and
it's just about you know bringing some
light to the world
that's awesome well listen
you weren't clowning around in this film
we're absolutely incredible david
arquette thank you for joining us you
can see scream in theaters nationwide
starting friday